here's The Good Wife's guide to how you can be a good wife to your husband
No. 1 have dinner ready
this should come as a no brainer
The way to a man's heart is always through his stomach
so make sure you plan ahead the night before
to ensure that he has a delicious meal when he comes home.
And make sure it's ready on time when he returns home from work
okay this ensures that he knows that you're thinking about him and his needs
he's at work trying to provide for you and your family
so make sure when he gets home
he has a warm meal ready for him
to relieve his stress and make him fall in love with you all over again
No. 2 you prepare yourself
make sure you take a couple minutes to yourself before he gets home
and freshen up
maybe take shower
Run a brush through your hair,
touch up your makeup,
you know you, want to feel fresh for his right
Not only that if you look good
you feel good
so this doesn't just help him
this helps you out too
remember he's been at work
he's been around office people or drabby people
you don't wanna be one of them
you want to be his breath of fresh air when he gets home
No. 3 be happy and interesting for him
His boring day might need a lift
so one of your duties is to provide him happiness and peace
4 tidy up the house
throw away any clutter before he gets home
he doesn't wanna come home after work
and you're chilling on the couch with a bag of chips,
and the house is chaos
instead tidy up the main parts of the house
you know wipe off the crumbs off the counter
this allows him to relax when he gets off work
No. 5 minimize noise in the house
okay you want your house to be calming environment when he gets off work
so make sure you do the laundry
do the vacuuming
all before he gets home
and encourage the children to have some quiet time
maybe put on a movie or put them down for a nap
When he gets home from a stressful day
he needs to relax and unwind
Reflect on this guide for how you can be a good wife to your partner